[Music]
baking soda is a white crystalline
powder
when added to dough it reacts with the
acidic ingredients to form bubbles
giving cakes and cookies a light and
fluffy structure
it's also used in livestock feed fire
extinguishers and detergents
[Music]
baking soda is also known as sodium
bicarbonate
it can be produced through a chemical
process or it can be mined from the
ground
[Music]
large mineral deposits exist in
northwest colorado
left behind as lakes evaporated millions
of years ago
mine operators dissolved the sodium
bicarbonate underground using hot brine
the brine is a mix of the minerals and
water left over from prior processing
[Music]
they pipe the higher concentration brine
to a processing facility about a mile
away
the brine collects in a holding tank
outside and flows through pipes into the
facility as needed
inside a technician tests the liquid and
confirms that the level of sodium
bicarbonate is adequate
then the brine flows through several
tanks
where heat exchangers gradually cool it
[Music]
this causes the sodium bicarbonate brine
to crystallize
making the granules larger and heavier
[Music]
the crystals sink to the bottom of the
last tank this forms a mixture of brine
and crystals
they pump this mixture into a device
called a hydroclone
the hydroclone spins out the brine
through the center
the crystals gravitate to the sides and
sink to the bottom
[Music]
this creates a sodium bicarbonate slurry
it has a meringue like consistency
[Music]
the slurry is about 40 sodium
bicarbonate at this point
[Music]
a lot of water has been removed but
there's still work to be done
as the dewatering continues the system
recaptures spent liquid
and pipes it back into the mine to
dissolve more minerals
the slurry goes for another spin this
time in a centrifuge
it rings out more water transforming the
slurry into something called wet cake
wet cake is 95 sodium bicarbonate
[Music]
next the wet cake travels to a mixer
that blends dry sodium bicarbonate
powder into it
the dry powder brings the moisture
content down to three percent
[Music]
next the wet cake makes a quick trip
through this dryer to remove the
remaining moisture
leaving pure baking soda
the baking soda now shakes through three
tiers of vibrating screens
the crystals are sorted by size
producing several different grades
[Music]
from brine to powder it's been quite a
journey
it's time to determine how this
naturally mined baking soda measures up
a technician dissolves some of the
baking soda in water
he adds an acid to neutralize the sodium
bicarbonate
this allows him to measure its purity
[Music]
he also places the different grades of
baking soda in a screening device
it vibrates to shake the granules
through perforations
verifying that the crystals have been
correctly graded by size
with the lab's approval this baking soda
is ready for the marketplace
a robotic arm picks up the bag and
transfers it to a fill station with a
scale below
[Music]
the scale signals when there's 55 pounds
of baking soda in a bag
prompting the fill nozzle to shut off
these 55 pound bags will be sold to
commercial bakeries
and companies that use large amounts of
baking soda daily
it will no doubt rise to the occasion
you